all right memphis it's been more than a
decade
what made you want to come back you know
i've got something to prove
so uh it's time to get after it have you
figured it out yet though lord
figured what out who the best is
the best yeah the best is it you
you'll see
you know i have to prove it's been over
10 years you know i got second place the
last time i was in the house i created
one of the best alliances in the game
the renegades
so it's time to prove that this other
renegade deserves that number one spot
um when you look back at that time i
mean i know it was years ago but
what was your fatal mistake anything you
would have done differently
yeah you know i wasn't the best at jury
management you know i wasn't
i wasn't in tune with how i was being
perceived from the people that i was
giving them the boot
so this time around it's going to be a
little bit different you'll see a little
bit of a softer side of memphis a more
adult version memphis 2.0
i mean some time has passed how would
you say you've changed and how will that
affect how your game play has changed
i mean i'm completely different you know
i have a five-year-old amazing son
river and you know i have multiple
businesses um for me
this is a business transaction that i
got to close in three months
i love that well what will happen to the
money is it going to be investment for a
new business oh 100
you know my goal take that money and you
know triple it so
wow uh so you have your son um
are you single i i'm i'm seeing a
special person right now but
what does that mean okay i've been
dating a little bit here and there but
there's a special there's a special
someone out there
all right well is that special someone
gonna stay strong on your mind or do we
have a potential for a showmance here
oh i don't know let's see who's in that
house and uh we'll see if it plays into
to the game that i have in store for
everyone
what's the game you have in store for
everyone i got a little cards in my
sleeve you know there's a lot of things
that
i've had time to reminisce and think
about you know it's been 10 years that's
a lot of time to think about uh
think about what i would do if i got got
my hands back in there so
you know you'll see a lot of different
stuff i'm gonna play um
a certain game where ultimately i'm not
necessarily trying to win
i'm trying to make sure no one else wins
so as soon as i see alliances starting
to form showmance is starting to form
guess what
if i see a showmance guess what that
dude's going to have a little
competition just kind of
just to mix it up a little bit all right
so you're not afraid to flirt you're not
afraid
no way come on come on look at me let's
go
lord what are you doing if i can get out
of this house right now let's go have a
drink
thanks but i i will politely decline um
so you you're also coming off of
quarantine
um how do you think that will affect
everybody mentally and emotionally to
have
been dealing with a global pandemic
probably trapped at home which is no
stranger to big brother contestants but
still
usually it's just in the house now
everybody's been on lockdown for months
already
yeah i mean it's kind of crazy you know
when i made the decision to come back
it's kind of like you know the world's
going to hell in a handbasket anyway so
might as well go away for a little bit
so i think people i think people will be
a little bit
playing a little bit of different game
you know people have been locked up
people haven't been living their normal
lives so
let's see what it what shakes out so
knowing that this was all stars who are
you excited to see
and who are you nervous to see if
they're in there well i mean
if dan decides to make an appearance and
put the renegades back in action then
then it's going to be on
so the house better watch out but i'm
excited to play with some people that
you know thought that they were the best
and that that have played after me and
maybe played before me
and you know a lot it's it's totally
different when you
you see some of these people and
interact with these people after these
after these shows ended and you know you
see a different version of everyone
they've never seen memphis the game
player so they see memphis the nice guy
you know here have a drink here let's go
out to dinner
that guy so they're going to see a
different side of me once we're in that
house
well since it has been a minute how do
you feel about going up against
house guests who have been on the show
more recently do they have a leg up on
you or do you have a leg up on them
i you know that's interesting i'm sure
there's gonna i'm an old guy now at this
point you know i'm the old man so
i think i think for me um
going against a younger player that
maybe had played last year the year
before
i think there's a level of um
there's a i don't know there's a level
level of being there a long time ago
that wasn't influenced by all these
other people's games for me i've
i look to the past and that's it so
these people that are new to the game
they've just seen the game as it is now
like i come from more old school style
player
and you know all these twists and this
and that and this different you know
little thing they do
it's not going to work on me you know
i'm straight to the point i'm direct
and i got one job to do and that's to
make sure everyone gets kicked out of
that house
and again knowing it was all stars and
uh
you apparently being open to a showmance
any women you are maybe hoping to see in
there
oh man that's a loaded question lauren
that's a loaded question
so we'll leave it up to y let's see what
happens let's see who we end up with see
who's
see who's in that house it sounds like
there are a couple people on your mind
ah maybe there might be water too you
want to name one or two
[Laughter]
oh you're just asking for it huh i sure
am
you know there there's uh for me it's
like being stuck with a beautiful woman
you know
that'll keep me occupied and you know
have someone to talk to you know
for me it's all about it's all about the
pillow talk so you know if christmas
decides to like show her
her face in that in that house it might
be uh you know someone that i could uh
at least have a good conversation with
do you think it will affect showmances
that single people are showing up having
potentially been
locked inside for four months oh for
sure people are gonna be it's gonna be
like ravaged animals for sure you better
watch out like i'm sure
people are not gonna be acting normally
look they've been wearing face masks
every time they're out of the house this
is the opportunity that we're going to
be around a lot of people
you know being able to you know not wear
a mask and
and give hugs and kisses and you know
it's a different world so in that house
everything's safe
so we're free of covid could this be the
most pda-packed season ever
i don't know we'll see we'll see i think
uh you know
times have changed and and we'll see how
people react and i don't know you know
i'm sure we'll shake it up a little bit
if you're just looking at
um age because you mentioned that who do
you think plays this game better
somebody who's a bit older somebody
who's a bit younger what are the
differences
i think the for me i look at myself and
i look at the way that i played over 10
years ago and i think about
the person that i was then i was a young
kid you know and i think now
you know the life experience the
traveling everything that i've done i
have a son
um i'm a father i think ultimately for
me
to play 11 years ago and then live an
amazing life
in an amazing experience life for the
past 10 years i think
my my reality that i live in now has
has created a different person where
ultimately i'm playing a different game
a more educated
a sophisticated game a more um just
methodical game overall so for me it's
very
you know i feel like i will have a upper
hand rather than going into the house
and then spending two
two two summers off and then coming
right back in like i've had a lot of
time to think
a lot of time to grow up and you know
it's a different version of me a better
version
and what do you think it'll be like when
you set foot back on that set again
uh emotional triggering
i don't know maybe some ptsd you know i
don't know
i'm not sure we'll see what i feel but i
i feel like the excitement's there the
anxieties there
you know it's definitely there i can
feel it i can feel it right now
but um i think once those doors shut
it's it's game time
you know there's something that switches
off in your head and you're ready to go
and
you're in that mode all right the last
thing what do you want to say
to the audience that's going to be
watching you about how you're going to
win
oh big brother audience memphis 2.0 is
coming for you
and you're going to see something and
you're going to see a lot of
entertainment
and i'm not going to play nice so get
ready for some some good tv